[Music]
well i have a
story of a 37 year old japanese man who
has built a very successful career
for doing nothing is that joke
that sounds like my dream so
he rents himself okay we're still
talking about joe
all right yeah i'm kind of doing that
right dude is this how we roast joe we
just like [ __ ] do this and then we
all just
directly passively aggressively roast is
this one of those guys that live
streamed them sleeping
no or no it's not that but along the
lines of that so what he does
is he rents himself out to strangers
letting them know ahead of time
that he can do nothing but eat drink and
just hang out
like just that's the best he'll give
like short responses
yeah so the only thing that he charges
for
is his transportation and any food and
drink that is involved
when he's there so he's like a couch
surfer pretty much
but you pay him but you're paying him
but you said a fortune
no it's just like he's built a
successful career is the way there
why do i want him to do this with me i'm
lonely yeah people are so lonely
and i work too much so i don't build any
relationships outside of work so he's
like a renault friend
yes i'd be a really good rental friend
you would be a good runner friend
yeah i would pressure people to have fun
well for him it just sounds like he's
just like there he was just there but
why would i want this guy
like yeah what does he bring to the
table is he handsome because i feel like
there's other people that do the same
thing and i can rent them for better
yeah
is he easy maybe if you're not maybe if
you're socially awkward it's way more of
a task
whereas with this it's like i'm awkward
i don't have to talk to this person but
i don't feel
lonely so the pressure's off so he's
been doing this for two years
he has over 270 000 twitter followers
he's made appearances on national
television in japan he's from tokyo by
the way
he's he's done interviews and magazines
and he even owns
books and manga manga manga yeah on
amazon
and so his name is shoji
does he have any testimonials of people
who have tried to give a yelp review
i would like to read the reviews all he
did was just chew
and shut the [ __ ] up perfect company
when he's hanging out with his friends
does he consider it freebies yeah he's
hooking him up
he's like yeah you know i'll give you a
couple yeah i actually charge for this
but you know i'll hook you up you'll be
fine
yeah so he actually he's actually quite
popular
and they they call him mr rental
mr randall oh he does so well that on
most days he leaves his home
around 8 30 a.m and he returns
at 10 p.m what a [ __ ] workaholic
yeah you must have to eat a lot i know
right i could not do this job
that's too much socialization mm-hmm
you'll get drowned
yeah i'd be like ma'am my energy is
drained yeah
i'd be drowned in all their energy yeah
i guess it works
but what makes him so special because i
feel like there might be other people
doing the same thing i demand to see him
at once
maybe he doesn't have competition he
puts himself out there a lot
is he filipino no you said japanese it's
brandon okay the homie
he looks like he's my little brother if
he was a chimpanzee
he looks like he's about to get punked
for lunch money and you
snap the photo that's for sure his face
looks scared
yeah that's a surprise photo that's the
only photo they provide that's horrible
they did him dirty he does feel
non-threatening like he doesn't feel
like
like it could go wrong and he just
chills and he has the perfect vibe to
find nothing though like he just
eats and drinks i'll tell you and one
word answers
so they're saying that uh
so there was this one assignment that he
got
where he was invited to a five-star
hotel by a man who visits five-star
hotels
about once a month as a hobby and the
person rented him because he wanted to
tell someone about his hobby
so he listened to him for three hours
talking about his hobby see that's what
i'm wondering
because i would i want to show them all
my hobbies because steve gets sick of it
and i want to show them him all my cats
and i want to show all my plans hey hey
pay us
money we don't want to hear this [ __ ]
[ __ ] for free yeah yeah you could
hire him to talk about eminem yeah yeah
yeah
and you're going to get it out of your
system you're like when you say nothing
like i need him to still respond and
validate it oh yeah it's like
he'll give short responses and stuff
like he'll still validate
like i need him to be like oh cool like
i need to i need to buy it i think he
would
i don't think he's gonna stare at you or
else like why would people want his
services
he probably gives good like
reciprocation to like all this [ __ ] dude
how many people do you think
try to [ __ ] him and they're like super
confused about the situation
like wait what do you mean no no no i
know yeah we're here to hang yeah you
take off your pants or whatever and he's
like no no
five star guy yeah for sure wanted no
like i'm actually
just an escort that's all i do i mean
isn't that what an escort does
plus sex but like minus the sex well
that's what the that's what they build
their time as
well they even say sugar babies right
not all of them [ __ ]
this is what they do they're companions
so how is this any different
he's a rented companion but apparently
in japan
like renting people is like a really
popular thing
you know conan o'brien did a
rent-a-family thing or was it jimmy
fallon one of them
but when renting a family came out they
did it and it was hilarious
how's he faring during kovid true
i don't know that do they beat it
already i don't know because i know a
lot of countries have already
and they're already just chill they're
pretty strict on travel but when i see
the
okay maybe it's because they've been
wearing masks it doesn't look any
different
so when i see them operating right and
they have like limited capacity anyway
which is like six people had it done
yeah
they've always been covered friendly
yeah so maybe that's why it doesn't look
any weird to me
i'll give you guys more examples so
another example
is he was asked to attend a wedding
ceremony by a person who for some reason
hadn't invited his friends he was asked
by a woman to accompany her as
she submitted a divorce report because
she was lonely and didn't have
anyone else to ask and he was asked
he was asked to ask behind a man who was
on trial
during a civil trial just so they could
feel supported by someone
wow yeah that's sad you know it was a
sad place it's very sad japan's
wedding thing makes sense you know why
okay picture this right
you're out of town like let's say you're
out of town for work like chicago or
something you have no family or friends
there
and then you have a co-worker who
invited you to a wedding
but you're not really friends with
anyone else because it's a new job
so you're just like [ __ ] i don't want to
go alone then you hire someone to just
roll with you
i haven't heard that kind of makes sense
or if it's like christmas time but
you're separated from your family
and you don't have like a spouse or
anything so you're like
um so you hire a hooker and you go to
the motel and you cry with her
for the next three hours that sounds
pretty good yeah who's this guy's number
one competitor
i don't know yeah how how much is his
rates does it say
well yeah he's very popular pretty much
a free free service
you're only paying for his
transportation and for his food
what the [ __ ] oh i missed that part whoa
why would he do it just like how does he
make money then i don't know
oh oh i do know no so in the beginning
he would only accept
that fee as a fee like transportation
and food and drinks but then
after his he got so popular people
insist on giving him tips
so he's just like well now i just kind
of got accustomed to it but at first i
felt really uncomfortable
but now he he just accepts i wonder what
like drove him to
get into this field so i can tell you
that
that's kind of a noble thing actually to
start off doing help lonely people
so it says that he was a model
student he worked hard got good grades
and graduated with a master's degree in
physics
from a prestigious osaka university he
got a job as a book editor at a
publishing house but in 2017 after three
years with the company he quit
realizing that it wasn't the career he
really it's boring
and so he said that the decision it's
not my passion
his decision was influenced by reading
nietzsche
whose work completely changed his
perspective on
life he says i went japan needs niche
though i went on to graduate school
because
the people around me were doing that so
i was just swept away without thinking i
rarely lived on my own
initiative so he said that he began
reconsidering his life after reading him
so it's really passion based and then he
realized that
he finds fulfillment and being company
for lonely people
that's cool yeah there are a lot of
lonely people out there
yeah you don't realize how how many
there are until like coveted and [ __ ]
honestly yeah and then i was i mean i
dude i've never been more lonely ever
because of all this [ __ ] and you have a
life partner
no i just mean you know how i am i grab
like i'm a social butterfly
friends family there's like tick tocks
of like remember the guy we're watching
he was just in his car and then he just
was trying to reach out to the world and
he
felt
so sad and he started breaking down and
just crying like he was wearing a suit
i don't understand how to be lonely so
it's like so foreign to me
that's where i'm at yeah yeah like
because you because you like
doing things on your own right oh no
like i'm constantly like it's easy for
me to like
hang out with people yeah i just call
them up or find people or like
over the years i've built such a network
of people
that i can't be lonely even if i choose
to same
but then i get what you're saying it's
like it's like you're so active
you're you don't feel the need for human
interaction because you're just
constantly
active and then you're tired you go to
sleep well she just got to the point
though where
she's like i need to see people well no
i said i got to the point where i
actually
was like huh i could hang out with
people
because i never met the threshold before
i never knew what that was because i
always
had like social functions that were like
kind of obligations and it's like
once i'm there i have fun but like i
really like to be at home
and then i found i found out that it's
about a month
about a month in i'm like i could hang
somewhere and have fun right now
like i think i could go socialize i um
can be alone too because i did that in
april
and then uh but i i do prefer
adventuring with people i think it's
it's a little bit more fun when the joy
is shared
yeah totally adventure is different i
like adventuring with other people
but if it's just like um going to the
same restaurant or the same place
person's house or the same like place
every time or like you know i just um
i get kind of drained too many times in
a row she can't do it too many of them
like too close to each other yeah like
what if you were on a trip with a group
of friends
for like a month that's different
because we're all we're all experiencing
something new together
so the stimulation is different yeah
that's interesting how this stuff works
out
i don't know because i think like us
going all the vegas is different than us
all going to a barbecue at one of our
houses right now yeah cause it's boring
i don't want to see your faces at a
barbecue
i love all that [ __ ] it's like there's
something to do you go there you eat and
then you're like
okay time to go home now you know i
don't know where i i
i don't know where i'm at anymore
because like just thinking about being
home
like completely alone gets me excited
and i'm like
oh [ __ ] like let's do that but then
like and then in the past i'm like [ __ ]
i can't be home alone i just i need to
be around people i need to get energy
from other people
and now i'm like people drain me now i
change
damn i don't know i don't think i have
the need for anything
it's just um things just happen and i'm
like all right let's roll
i've been wanting to steal people's dogs
okay well because
fan was our last puppy that passed away
and then so now i've been seeing dogs
and go
oh i want a dog now and i just wanna and
i see people's puppies i just wanna take
them oh yes i wanna steal kids sometimes
wait what because they're cute yeah i'd
be like come on dude
no kids like i got fatherly jeans and
[ __ ] you know sometimes i wanna cook a
small little it's all offended i got
fatherly g's [ __ ] i want to make a cute
little
mini hamburger like i got a i got an
adult hamburger and a mini
i just [ __ ] feed that kid that [ __ ]
and i go all right cool go play on the
swings
don't you live with uh two kids that's
why but i've been gone for a month
oh you missed them yes like i mean just
just having a booger like when i got
home
i worked out and i saw two of them just
face pressed against the [ __ ] back
door and you can see their lips all up
on it and then they're waving to me like
hi
uncle that's awesome yeah and you're
like i work out naked
pretty much and i'm there going like
this and christina's like yup
that's my neighbor wonderful i'm just
like yay and i'm just [ __ ]
in my calisthenics i'm waving at them
like yeah
they're going yay and then i come back
and then they do it again yay
no aunt has three kids i guess so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you